all right we are we're now live it looks
like and uh we've got first AMA of the
new year so got some questions already
lined up so I thought I would start just
a few minutes early it's a snowy morning
here in Milwaukee so nice and cozy to uh
settle in and do some philosophy and so
here's the first question and and this
is an interesting one given that you've
taught a lot in prisons have you ever
seen philosophical insights Aid people
in processing guilt if so any stories
you'd be willing to share so first I
have to say that it's been a while since
I've taught face- tace in prisons and
I've I've only taught in three systems
so the first one was my first full-time
teaching job for Ball State University
when Indiana was still doing real prison
education and not farming it out to Ivy
Tech and um that was for six years
full-time so that was a lot that was
pretty intensive and I I got to see a
lot of uh
interesting Reflections and Reformation
on the part of people that would fit in
with this and then my second time was in
the North Carolina system and that
didn't last very long
um I taught at Samson correctional
institute just for a semester in an
outreach program that fville State
University had and then I taught for two
years here online because they don't
have
face-to-face college education in the
second chance pel program that uh
Milwaukee Area Technical College was
running here in Wisconsin and so you
know those prisoners could be like all
over the state but you don't get a lot
of direct interaction and one of the
things that was like totally missing in
those classes was interaction between
the students themselves which is kind of
a problem you know for for the kind of
thing that you're asking about because
you do need students to be engaging with
each other so yeah in in I can talk
about the Ball State uh teaching that
was from 2002 to
2008 and you know when I think about it
what texts and thinkers were
particularly helpful for these
prisoners thinking about their own
situations their lives the crimes that
they had committed the ones they had
gotten away with as well the
relationships that they had well you can
guess it would be a lot of thinkers who
were talking about ethics so you know
that that was quite helpful for them and
then you know I taught religious Studies
classes as well and ethics winds up
being a significant part of many
religions and so we study that and you
know we would talk about Buddhism or
Christianity or Hinduism or you know
various indigenous religions and what
they had to contribute there was also a
significant uh Muslim Sunni Muslim
population at Indiana State Prison as
well and so you know it it was it wasn't
as if you could predict that oh if I
pick this text or thinker these people
will respond to it in this positive way
or anything like that um instead it was
more occasional right they had to be in
the right frame of mind for the stuff to
provoke them into thinking about their
life and how they wanted to change it
but I did get to see quite a bit of that
and some of it was you know the Texs and
thinkers that you would kind of predict
that you would run into say in ethics
classes like uh Plato and Aristotle and
epicus um you know
Augustine Thomas aquinus but also you
know like Marx shayer um was uh somebody
who they they found quite interesting
and responded to quite a bit um I had a
contemporary philosophy class where we
we read him and uh there were some other
thinkers I'd have to really think
because we're talking about 15 to 20
years ago so not not that much really
comes to mind I will say this so you're
looking for stories there was a student
that I had who came into prison as a
Neo-Nazi and he had a giant swastika
tattooed on one of his
shoulders and over time he got very
interested in stoicism this is long
before like it was on a lot of people's
radar and that Drew him into studying
Buddhism of all things and not the sort
of like Zen anything can be anything
Buddhism that Americans typically do but
like actual theava Buddhism and he
started trying to live as a monk in his
following as many of the precepts as
possible and after a while partly
through Reading Marx shayer who is
somebody very sympathetic as a uh
Catholic thinker to Buddhism um he found
himself being drawn into Christianity
and he converted and one of the things
that he did as part of that conversion
was he had that tattoo massively redone
and it was a lot of ink involved first
in the the the swastika and then in the
redoing of it and he had it like
reworked into this incredible cross and
I thought that that was kind of a
cool um symbol of his tangible
conversion along the way and confronting
you know what he had done and what he
became and what he wanted to change
himself into too so all right um laps 9
Continuum do you think it's ever helpful
to compare terms or concepts between
thinkers for example haider's category
for honden height and any of hegel's
uses of immediate being or better not to
compare at all so I I'd say you got a
false dichotomy there and really what
you want is more in the middle um and it
depends on what you mean by compare so
you don't want to do the sloppy sort of
well I see this the same term here so it
must mean the same thing over here I'll
give you an example of that so the Greek
term thumos in Plato and in Aristotle
and in the stoics it doesn't mean
exactly the same thing right in Plato
it's actually like part of our soul the
part that gets angry in Aristotle it is
one main mod of affectivity of which
anger or is a major part and sometimes
thumos is just a syn
for anger in the stoics thumos is a
particular mode of anger and you can say
this also with later authors like for
example John
Cassian um and with with other you know
people who are bringing these terms in
uh John christm would be another good
example as well and so you know you want
to be a bit careful and so the example
that you have there for hanen height you
know um and and Hegel use of uh
immediate being or
unmediated you know uh when m barus v
and or
um uh Z right they're not exactly the
same thing but you could draw
comparisons between them provided you're
being careful in not identifying them
with each other um but you know how far
can any of these comparisons go you know
only only so far right so you do want to
exercise some caution and with somebody
like haiger and Hegel so haiger talks
about Hegel quite a bit I think in that
case you might actually look to see what
haiger says about Hegel he's got
lectures on the
phenomenology and he brings up um Hegel
as well in a number of other works
including being in time so that you know
when you've got a case like that um
there might actually be things where
hidinger saying well I'm doing something
similar or here's where Hegel got
something wrong or I'm doing something
completely different so I think that
could be quite useful as
well um maximum hi Dr s what work of
epicus do you recommend to start with I
already read some Marcus and most works
of senica I mean this is very
straightforward uh we only have two
works of
epicus um we have uh the discourses and
then we have the nidian uh both of which
are actually not by epicus but by his
student areas and who um you know sort
of like zenfon to Plato's zenfon to
Socrates right he's a historian a
military guy writes down some of the
things that his his teacher had said
that he thought are important um there's
also things out there like the golden
sayings but put that crap aside don't
don't buy into that um there's you know
those are mostly drawn from frag Ms
which we're not really sure if they're
accurate or not a lot of people draw
fake quotes from that sort of
thing just read the epicus you're gonna
have to reread it and reread it anyway I
suppose you could start with the end
creating if you want to but there's
nothing that says you have to you know
if you if you've actually read all of
Marcus's meditations and you've read a
lot of Sena that's a lot of stuff well
then you're probably ready for the
discourses you know so why not why not
jump into the Fuller work you know uh
Eric Hendry I see a lot of content you
have on Plato but not much on
neoplatonism from what I can see what's
your thoughts on neoplatonism platinus
in particular well I think that
neoplatonism is interesting but it sure
as hell isn't just
platinus and you know I actually do have
a lot of work on neoplatonic authors but
you have to actually be able to identify
them as neoplatonic neoplatonism in
includes Jewish neoplatonism Pagan
neoplatonism and Christian
neoplatonism and you know when we talk
about um the early church fathers most
of them are neoplatonists so I I do have
a lot of stuff on
Augustine canel is arguably a Christian
plist I actually have an article out
there on that so you know I actually do
have a lot of content on people who are
broadly play plist um or neoplatonist
and I have some stuff on middle
platonists as well so you know I think
that um it's interesting so 18 s had
this great observation about
augustinians right he said that um there
isn't like a common Essence that you can
identify uh as you can with some
philosophical schools to say ah this
person is a augustinian therefore they
must believe all of this he said
something along the lines of you can
tell this somebody is an austinian but
you don't know what kind of augustinian
they're going to be and we can say the
same thing about neoplatonism can't we
so um yeah I've I've done quite a bit of
work on various neoplatonists over over
time uh who framed the
um Socratic method Mary walstone crafts
got something against virtue ethics as
construed in her time but also seems to
dislike male Vice should we read her in
rhetorical Frameworks Mary walstone
craft is a virtue ethicist so if you've
read her and gotten the idea that she
has something against virtue ethics
you've misread her she is clearly a
virtue ethicist that is there from the
beginning in the very first chapter uh
actually I think on the first page of
the Vindication of the rights of women
she talks a lot about virtue and vice
and her other works like the letters
from uh Norway Denmark and and and uh um
Sweden and in her letters to other
people and and in the Vindication of the
rights of man um so you know I've
actually been saying for years that she
is a unrecognized because of being a
woman voice in virtue ethics in the 18th
century so you might want to go back and
and look at her stuff
again um Santa K do you think there's
positive evil or is evil a kind of lack
of things a negative thing yes both I
think I think that evil is not something
that we have to try to come up with a
single definition or Essence of I think
there's lots of different kinds of evil
and sometimes evil is more a privative
and sometimes it's more something
existing in its own right I think the
problem that people get into is they
don't distinguish between different
kinds of being or existence that overlap
with each other so you know you could
look at somebody like anom for example
who takes the augustinian notion of evil
as privation and in his Works kind of
parses that out and says here's where
it's it's something positive here's
where it's something merely privative um
I don't think we have to choose between
those and I think that it's typically a
mistake to try to come up with one
single notion of evil that covers every
um possible category of
it Sans C says if you've read it you
have an opinion on adorno's negative
dialectics I'm very interested in it but
I know it is a reputation for being very
difficult and poorly translated in
English I would avoid people's
reputations because most of the time
they're they're just relying on they're
sort of regurgitating what other people
say and often they're full of crap right
um you want to ask people people who
actually have read adorno and perhaps
you know taught or written on adorno
those sorts of questions as it so
happens one of my very earliest
Publications is on adorno's negative
dialectics and his work against
epistemology you can find it out there
quite easily by just Googling Sadler
adorno dialectic uh it's been
anthologized into other people's
Collections and cited quite a bit uh
it's not a I won't say it's a great
article I mean it's from my graduate
school stuff um I actually considered
writing my Master's thesis on adorno I
took two classes on him in graduate
school because my mentor was a big fan
so we read negative dialectics we read
against epistemology we read the
aesthetic Theory I work through Minima
moralia on my own and adorno is a
difficult writer um he is a you know
really deep thinker um sometimes he says
things that are boneheaded like oh jazz
is bad or stuff like that but you can
kind of put that aside you don't have to
buy into everything that the guy says um
and I'll tell you this uh thank God he
is translated because in the original
German you actually in order to read his
work you need German English French
Latin and Greek because there's all
sorts of passages in there that are just
in the original language and adoro knew
all of those languages and probably some
some more as well
so you know there's there's nothing like
actually jumping in and trying it and
I'll say something a little bit broader
um there's no reason why you can't go to
the library so you don't even have to
buy the book or get a PDF of it online
right um and start reading and find out
for yourself whether the reputation that
people are ascribing to these things is
actually true and to what degree it is
true um there's nothing that you don't
need anybody's permission to start
reading a text uh I mean if I had to
wait for that I wouldn't have read three
quarters of the books that I've read in
the course of my career and I've
benefited from so much so all right um
Brandon uh Philosophy of Law question
should Clarence Thomas recuse himself
for conflict of interest yeah this is a
no-brainer is not only Thomas but all of
the corrupt justices who have taken
bribes from their uh donors of all sorts
of sorts and then covered it up I mean
that's the thing that tells you the most
they didn't just like come out and say
yeah I'm taking bribes uh you know I
think I can be objective they had to
hide it and pretend that that wasn't the
case and then you had you know forget
whether it was Roberts or Alo whining
like a little baby oh people are being
mean to US Supreme Court Justices you
know I mean come on this is the sort of
thing that is so clearly wrong from not
just a legal perspective but a moral
perspective so poisonous to our
Democratic institutions in our society
and the Supreme Court at this point has
less legitimacy in the eyes of the
American public
than Congress does and that's going
pretty darn low isn't it you know so I
mean what we really ought to do but of
course we don't have the apparatus to do
it is make a clean sweep of the whole
Fring court and start again you know or
I I think maybe if we if we're not going
to get rid of these deeply corrupted
partisan justices I'm all for packing
the court with better legal Scholars you
know we are stuck with these
we we've got a bunch of people who are
corrupt and shouldn't be on the court
like Clarence Thomas because of that but
arguably also Alo and Roberts and then
we've got people who are just like well
and Kavanaugh I mean look at him we've
got people who shouldn't be on the court
at all because they're not even good
lawyers or judges you know the people
that that Trump snuck in with that
Republican Congress where you're like
holy crap there are like thousands of
people people more qualified than these
non- entities right uh so you know this
is not a tough one for Philosophy of Law
I think right so that's that's that's a
an interesting one but can we do
anything about it no and that's a big
problem with American politics is given
our highly polarized system and the fact
that we've got this constitutional
apparatus that maybe worked well at one
point in time but sure is held doesn't
work now there's nothing we can do right
we are stuck with these governing Elites
totally unaccountable for their quite
frankly evil actions you
know all right um let's see here Petro
says what do you make of classical
versus neoclassical theism I don't make
anything of it because I don't even know
what the hell the difference is between
classical and neoclassical theism that
strikes me as one of those distinctions
that gets made in a really parochial
corner of philosophy of religion or
religious studies and the rest of us
doing work don't actually know what
these people over here mean by that so I
I don't have any useful answer for you
on that one and I will say this by way
of digression there's a lot of that isms
in philosophy especially among analytic
philosophers where they come up with a
term and they think that like all of us
actually use it but it's just them and
their little circle of friends and their
followers that are using these sorts of
distinctions um you know sometimes they
catch on well but once they do then
there's a whole bunch of different
versions about what those terms end up
meaning so I don't have anything to say
about about that uh Abraham says uh
which gek and helenistic readings do you
recommend on the topic of
anxiety well you're not going to find a
hell of a lot on anxiety in the modern
sense so I wouldn't actually recommend a
lot of readings from uh ancient uh Greek
well I mean helenistic is Greek you know
right um but what you can do is look up
what people have to say about fear and
how it impacts our lives and whether the
fears are rational and then you've got
like an entire
panoply of authors that you can read so
you know you've got Plato and Aristotle
they both discuss the emotions so do the
stoics uh the epicurian talk about this
as a matter of fact one of the parts of
the you know four-fold remedy is not
fearing the gods right not having
worries that the gods are going to be
pissed off at you and smite you or stuff
like that uh we have all sorts of great
eclectic authors you know Cicero
discusses fear we you know when we move
into uh late Antiquity so beyond the
helenistic period and into the the Roman
Imperial period we have even more
authors who are talking about fears
including some of the early Christian
writers and uh Jewish writers um so
there's there's a ton of people out
there you're just not going to find a
lot of them talking about like you know
anxiety in the sense of like fear that
doesn't have a direct object as we find
saying haiger and Sarge right um because
that's a more modern conception of
things although you will find people
along the way I think about Pascal and
his remark about the uh you know um the
universe as it is now and the fear that
it inspires in him that might be anxiety
right so you know you'll just have to
dig around in all of those sort of
thinkers uh Isaac oh this is a really
interesting interesting one where do you
find that students struggle the most
when reading Plato's euther so there's
there's two uh things actually three
I'll say
three and and one of them is broader
than just the
ethero so a lot of people will read
these texts either like in an
introduction to philosophy class or in
the euther maybe in a philosophy of
religion class or um they'll be reading
on their own but they're using a guide
and the guide will be telling them you
should be looking at this in the text so
in platonic dialogues and this holds
across the board they are never just
about the main topic that they're
supposed to be about so the Mino can we
Define virtue well it turns out that in
the Mino we can't although we can in
other dialogues um but it's not just
about defining virtue it's also about
the relationship between the virtues and
each other and it's about the you know
so-called Mino Paradox and
Socrates and his method and you know can
virtue be taught by anybody and how do
we know that in society there's all
these topics involved there or think
about the fat uh you know fat or on the
soul yes it is about the soul it's also
about mythology it's also about the the
real nature of the virtues by the way
there's a text where you know Socrates
actually does Define for us what genuine
Temperance and courage look like um and
S similarly with the euth ofro is it
just about the nature of piety that's a
main topic but we also have really
interesting stuff along the ways about
this guy youth afro and is he doing the
right thing and Prosecuting his father
uh why do the gods and human beings
disagree with each other right there's
more than that going on so that's the
first thing where students I think run
into uh Pro s and another uh thing is
they come into it and they're like this
is all about not just piety but the
ethro Dilemma there is no efro dilemma
in the ufro so it's kind of a misnomer
right the text provides a launching
point for talking about this thing that
people later on are very very very
interested in but isn't actually in the
text itself as a dilemma
sort of like the ontological argument
anom does not have an ontological
argument because it doesn't get called
that until Kant right uh and anom you
know the sort of things that dekart and
Spinosa are doing and that Kant is
targeting they're not what anom is doing
he doesn't talk about like a you know
greatest possible being that's later
people anom actually tells gillo who's
criticizing him for making arguments
about you know a greatest possible
Supreme Being that's not the same thing
as that then which nothing greater can
be thought one works for the argument
the and the argument by the way is the
whole of the prian minus um the last
three chapters not it works for that
doesn't work for the other thing so if
you come to it with these blinders on oh
I got to be looking for the euther
Dilemma you're G to screw yourself up
right the third thing is the actual
discussion about you know being loved by
the gods or you know why you know is is
the pious loved by the gods because it
is loved uh you know or is it uh you
know loved because there's something
about it okay that's a tricky argument
and and it's really quite complicated
it's not as simple as what people call
the euth ofro dilemma and I think that
trips people up as well they're like
what the hell's going on here right it's
it's a dialectic that um you have to
kind of work your way through so that's
a that's a great question
about um where students go
wrong uh Santa says genuinely curious
how have you been lately anything new
that you might not mind sharing I mean
I'm pretty open about what's going on in
my life I think you know a lot of you
see me at almost home cat rescue
engaging with the cats uh one of them
recently uh had to be taken into uh
Foster with our Animal Welfare officer
because it's it's got a virus and I'm
blanking on the name of it I want to say
FIP but I might be mixing that up um and
it's something that that cats have the
the virus in them already but it can
mutate and then cause this ultimately
fatal thing um you know and I put out
almost homes call for fundraising to
which people have actually responded
quite well um that's Kenji who who's a
you know adorable little golden cat
who's very sweet who came in with his
brother nbit um you know so I'm
concerned about them uh I'm getting the
semester ready to roll I mean I will say
this um I I have a class an online class
for those who are interested it there's
actually a link in this video
description that is now enrolling that
will be starting on Thursdays I want to
say the 25th and it's ancient philos
philosophers on friendship and that has
90 minute class sessions with me every
week for 10 weeks we're going to read
Plato and Aristotle the epicurian Cicero
Sena epicus dioc christum plutar uh
Lucian I think that's everybody I might
be leaving somebody out so that's GNA be
I mean that's something I I'd like to
put on people's radar I've also started
um doing Cameo videos where people um
you know they ask for somebody to do a
video for themselves or for their um
their friend or partner stuff like that
so that's that's kind of new right I put
a link to that in the video description
as well so if people are interested in
that they can check it out my health is
you know getting better um I need to get
out and start walking more uh but that's
kind of a matter of time uh finding the
time and uh yeah I mean things are going
pretty good for a guy who's in his 50s
and uh always has more work to do than
he can get done in any given day so all
right so um I'm probably gonna
mispronounce this uh sagri Ki I've been
watching your video series about
Aristotle and Plato for the last two
months it's been very useful do you find
the post structuralist worth reading
most of them feel like a copy of the
German philosophers of the 19th century
20th century so um glad that the videos
have been useful for you post
structuralists are not a copy of German
philosophers from the 19th or 20th
century um they are worth reading
although selectively right so let's take
dereda as an example Dara's uh early
works like on grammatology the essays in
writing indifference speech and
phenomena all definitely worth reading
you know rigorous philosophical work
that's often quite
insightful um that's great his later
stuff towards the end of his life like
the gift of death politics of friendship
uh operas worth reading as well the
stuff that's kind of in between you know
where he uh became a star and and would
just like you know engage in all sorts
of Play and games and stuff like that
yeah you can read it if you want to but
it's kind of a waste of time and you're
probably I mean you don't go to dareda
for say understanding Hegel or Freud or
people like that um but it's worth
reading Fuko is definitely worth reading
Duo is worth reading I'm less of a fan
of Delo when he's with gari although Duo
loved him um I kind of think that his
writing suffers in interest and rigor
when he's working with qari you know
leotard is another person um and it's
worth reading the structuralist too you
know uh Fair non dissur course on
General Linguistics really interesting
stuff um those structural linguists like
yakobson and hels Lev really worth
checking out as
well um so yeah there's you know it's
it's good to read these these post
structuralist authors they often have
some pretty interesting stuff to put on
the table and think about and it's not
just reducible to 19th century German
philosophy so
yeah all right Sarah saysi just started
studying logic science I'm assuming you
mean hegel's science of logic but I
don't know what to reply on can you give
me oh maybe maybe you're studying logic
can you give me suggestions books
lectures um there's I mean if you're
studying formal logic there is actually
a video channel out there um Sarah
something or other and her name she goes
under the moniker if I remember right Dr
logic and she's she's done a whole video
series because she teaches that like
full-time and her stuff is good you know
um I think there's a longer title to to
that um I mean you can get any logic
textbook and they're more or less going
to cover the same ground if you're
really interested in the foundations of
logic well there's this guy who is a big
name in logic uh Irving copi who wrote a
very important textbook that has been
redone over and over and over again but
he also wrote books about logic itself
as a science and discipline and then if
you want to go like further back there's
like all sorts of textbooks that you can
find on internet archive that are logic
textbooks that you know deal with the
topic in interesting and different ways
I liked Lewis Carroll's symbolic logic
which you can often find in used
bookstores um that was actually working
through the puzzles and problems in that
was part of how I ended up maxing one
section of the gr The Graduate record
examination back when I was in in
undergraduate um you know so there's
there's lots of resources and any good
logic textbook is is kind of G to go
over the same stuff they'll probably
start you on on ristian logic which is
derived from Aristotle but is not all
from Aristotle it's really what the
medievals did and then they'll talk
about modern formal logic they'll go
through you know um truth tables and
vend diagrams and you know predicate
logic and then they might get into the
cool you know weird stuff like fuzzy
Logics or deontological logic or
modalities you know and and cool stuff
like that right and there's there's
books that you can get out there on that
but I I don't have a recommendation as
such for you because there's just like a
whole ton of them and the great news is
you can find a lot of this online or at
your local library uh and just start
working through it you know and there's
there's other people out there who do
that kind of work in YouTube um I don't
really need to replicate what what
they're doing right there's no need for
me to be straying over into their area I
don't get all the work done that I want
to get done as it is so
all right
um let's see here uh Chris says what are
your thoughts on the thesis that
existence was not a notion in Greek
Philosophy expounded by Scholars like
Charles Khan never heard of Charles Khan
so I don't I don't know what his shtick
is um it it all depends on what you mean
by existence right so existencia in
Latin is a term that eventually comes in
but it you know even in like the Middle
Ages it doesn't necessarily mean
existence the way that we typically
think of it but it's not as if we have a
single notion of existence so I don't
really know enough about his thesis to
be able to say much of anything I
mean if he's saying something like the
Greeks didn't think things existed well
clearly that's wrong you know U I would
actually take a look at sona's letters
he has a letter which is not about
existence as such but about being and
the different meanings of it that he
says are there in
Plato uh and he distinguishes between a
whole bunch of these and you might find
what you're you're looking for in there
um but I I don't know enough about his
thesis to really say much I'm I'm
assuming that there's going to be a lot
of provisos and
qualifications because that is a very
very bold thesis to have and who knows
what the hell he means by exist distance
you know uh we don't all mean the same
thing think about kard versus
yaspers versus uh sart versus all these
other people that that talk versus like
you know what logicians mean when they
say existence right uh Max says uh I
wanted to thank you for the proma videos
I think they will be very useful for me
when I reread the text sometime in the
future after reading the primary text
what are some tips for getting a lot out
of secondary literature be besides
remembering there certain
interpretations of a text so
um yeah I'm I'm not quite done with the
proma I actually shot two videos
yesterday that I'll be
releasing uh a little bit later on I've
got two more yet to produce and uh then
I'll be done with the promen and I I'll
be glad because it's a cool work but I
don't want to be talking about K all the
time I got got other stuff that I want
to be doing including shooting this
commissioned video on delus and the body
without organs that somebody requested
from me a while back and some videos
here and there about existentialist
thinkers because I'm I'm doing
existentialism again this semester and
then I've got a lot of other things I I
need to get to um now primary text and
secondary literature um yeah so you read
the primary text first at least once and
then um you can go to secondary
literature and it is good to remember
that secondary literature you know some
of the secondary literature might not
really be coming from an agenda or a
take or a perspective I think that
Friedrich Cobblestone is pretty good
with that I mean his his agenda was
helping his students figure out what the
hell these texts were talking about and
so he includes lots of passages and he
he will tell you this is my
interpretation or this is what other
thinkers think about this sort of thing
he's very honest about that whereas some
secondary interpreters are a little bit
disingenuous in saying well as we all
know you know this is the case and
you're like come on buddy that's that's
not true you know um so you know taking
their interpretations with the
proverbial grain assault is helpful and
you know it could be good to think about
well what are their what are their
assumptions what are their
presuppositions going into this and when
they have beefs with other people try to
figure out okay what's this argument
back and forth H about is it a real
issue or not so I'll give you an example
of
this in the late 90s and early 2000s
primarily among analytic philosophers
who are interested in Aristotle there
was a big scholarly discussion that in
my mind was what we call a nothing
burger right it's it didn't have to
happen and it was kind of off base is
Aristotle an egoist or an altruist
because when we look at the nickam mccan
ethics on friendship it looks like we're
getting something out of our friendships
in every case which would make him an
egoist you know and you're like these
categories don't really work for
Aristotle's you know thought and didn't
you read you know book nine of the nick
of McCain ethics where Aristotle
actually distinguishes between good and
bad forms of selflove the answer was
right there if you weren't such a crappy
scholar you know and so sometimes we get
secondary literature and and we have to
like be you know careful about it
because we're like these people didn't
do their due diligence so actually
that's one of the things maybe you want
to look look at the secondary literature
does the person
actually understand the philosopher in a
comprehensive way or are they just kind
of like selectively picking stuff out of
the works to suit The Narrative or
predeliction that they have which is
often I just want to I want to publish
something and I want to talk with my
buddies about it you know so that's
that's important to keep in mind I would
say
um stoic says I don't have any questions
just want to say that you're wholesome
yeah I've been told that I'm not quite
sure what that term means anymore than I
fully understand what the young people
mean by based or you know the this mood
or jargon or stuff like that we we'll
see how much of these terms manage to
stick in our
vocabulary uh Generations down the line
who knows maybe maybe some of them will
become like really part of our language
and maybe some of them will disappear
the way slang has uh from previous
generations you know where we we look at
it kind of
ironically um so all right John Geral
have you read any Edward glissant or
Buckminster Fuller so I've never even
heard of Edward glissant Buckminster
Fuller was kind of a big deal where I
went to graduate school Southern
Illinois University there's actually a
ton of Buckminster Fuller Bucky Balls
around in that area and I I don't it's
been so long I don't really
remember the connection maybe he was
down there for a while and hanging out
with them during the Heyday when SIU was
building under President or Chancellor
delete Morris who built it up from a
teacher's college into a research
institution um but I don't really
remember and I I I do remember reading a
few things of his way way way back then
but I couldn't tell you what they were
or what I got from them so I think that
the impression that I got was H
interesting guy but nothing here that I
really want to
explore uh which doesn't mean you know
anything about him there's so many
authors that 20 years ago I read and
didn't quite get what they were doing
and you go back to them later on you're
like holy crap look at all the stuff I
missed including people like say
friederick nche right so
I I don't really have much to say about
about um
Fuller but you
know yeah all right so mole Plum H why
do you think MOX sterer is a dead end
why what would you read alongside his
text the unique in his property to
deepen your understanding of his work I
don't think he's a dead end I just think
that um I I'll say a few things a lot of
the people that are into him wind up
being kind of dorks and jerks and I I
don't really want to hang out with those
those people I did have a student one
time who uh wanted to focus on the
unique or the ego and its property you
know um and uh I had to abandon it
because the student just turned out to
be kind of a
wacko um and ended up blocking them in
various social media so sterer does tend
to attract a weird crowd you could say
um it's an interesting work you know
it's um
the the I think maybe what you're you're
getting is his notion of like putting
together a community of steran egoists
that ain't gonna happen um that's that's
kind of a not only a dead end but a a
project that just won't won't see
fruition and you know if you want to be
a um sternan egoist uh whatever you want
to call it go ahead but don't expect
anyone else to like buy into your thing
if you were a good starian you wouldn't
expect anyone else to buy into it right
it's a philosophy for
individuals um what would you read
alongside his text to deepen your
understanding of his work I guess what I
would do is like read good intellectual
histories that talk about what happened
with
hegelianism as it as after Hegel dies it
you know spirals off into all these
interesting different directions often
times we say well there were the left
hegelians and the right hegelians it's
way more complicated than that you know
and sterer is definitely using hegelian
terminology and Concepts throughout his
work isn't he um so you know he fits
into that that
Matrix um so you know that might be what
you want to check out
right all right uh orille what direction
do you see the field of philosophy
taking over the next 10 or 20 years I
don't see the field of philosophy taking
a direction because I don't think there
is a uh single field of philosophy I
think there's a whole bunch of
overlapping and intersecting fields of
this thing that we call
philosophy and they're going in
different uh directions themselves and
even within you know big things like say
Continental or analytic philosophy or
history of philosophy there's a million
different projects going on so I I don't
know you know I I can talk about uh
movements a bit more you know um like
you know for example uh philosophy is a
way of life which goes way back before
piure Ado and um Ado himself admits that
right um but sometimes his followers are
like oh Ado started something new you
know um that's certainly going in some
interesting directions we have a lot of
cool literature out there that's like
recognizing rightly that uh certain
things that we thought of is only like
theoretical movements actually have very
important practical implications for how
you would live your life um but that's
only like one tiny little current
there's there's so much going on in
philosophy and all of its connected
disciplines that I don't know I'm not
going to make predictions about that
um all right uh and
Rodriguez wish you a Happy New Year I'm
reading Norman P Barry lately I'm in the
middle of on classic liberalism and
libertarianism are you familiar with
Barry's work not at all um but you know
there's probably 99% of the people
who've written books I'm not familiar
with their work because there's so many
books out there you know so uh you know
it'd be interesting to know what you you
make of it um laps n Continuum do you
think ship of thesis type questions are
worth thinking about can serious
philosophical attempts at answering such
questions uncover deep truths about the
world or is it a waste of time it's
neither right um I I wouldn't the the
ship of thesis is this idea that you
have a ship and overtime every single
part of the ship is replaced is it the
same ship goes all the way back to
Plutarch right um and are you going to
discover deep truths about the World by
considering these these sort of
questions probably not but is it waste
of time no definitely not I'll give you
a prime example of this from the the
classic metal class that Scott truli and
I do monthly uh we'll be doing one this
month by the way which will include an
interview with somebody who's been in in
here asking questions quite a bit over
the years in amas uh kenned Blackwell
where we'll be looking at the new wave
of British heavy metal so one of the
ship of thesis
applications is is thinking about the
question when a band no longer has
original members is it really still the
same band or or not I mean it has legal
continuity and it has kind of a musical
continuity but it might not actually be
the same band but you could also have a
band that veers off in such a different
direction that in some ways it's not
even the same band so thinking about
what does it take like can you have a
band that is the same band if it doesn't
have any original members so for example
finin Lizzy is out there and playing
obviously Phil lot one of the major you
know inspirers of the band central
figure died years ago his um death date
or birth date was actually just recent
um and the only um non original but like
classic era memory M of the band still
left is Scott Gorham and he's the band
leader right he's the the lead
guitarist um is that still Thin Lizzy or
not well that's a ship of thesias
problem isn't it because he was a
replacement player along with Brian
Robertson um or you know I mean it's
kind of interesting when let me of
Motorhead died right obviously no
original members left at that point
because fast Eddie Clark was already
dead and Phil Taylor was dead but
motohead did still have Phil Campbell
who still exists plays with his his uh
ban Phil Phil Campbell and the bastard
sons and still had Mickey D who's now
with the Scorpions right and uh Phil
Campbell and um Mickey D said we're not
gonna try to have Motorhead without L
wouldn't make any sense right so maybe
there's some Irreplaceable Parts in some
potential ships of Theus that you just
can't do without right could you have
Iron Maiden which has been a pretty
coherent unit over the years without
having Steve Harris I don't think so
right so maybe if we consider the ship
athus maybe there's some parts that you
just can't swap out right could you have
Judas Priest without Ian
Hill maybe you could could you have ACDC
without Angus Young don't think so right
so these ship aesus problems can in fact
be quite useful now when it comes to
like sports teams there's no member of
the Green Bay Packers that is an
original member because they're all dead
team's been around for over a hundred
years um and we expect that sports teams
are going to change their personnel
right um so is that a different kind of
situation than a musical outfit you know
these are interesting questions now are
these really deep philosophical
questions I don't consider them so deep
but you know it's it's interesting to
think about isn't it so it does have
some usefulness I would say all right
Julian I've been influenced a lot by
Continental philosophers as opposed to
the tight logical argumentation of
analytic schools I wonder if if what I'm
reading thinking is real philosophy you
think a diet of strictly Continental
thinkers is
misformed of just one kind of philosophy
is going to misfor you no matter what
you pick right whether it's classical
American and you only read Dewey and
James and purse and you know other uh
figures like Roy um Continental you
could actually just be reading
phenomenologists or just marxists or
something like that um you clearly
haven't read much analytic philosophy if
you think that they are characterized by
tight logical argumentation because some
of their stuff is really sloppy and
loose and appealing to like intuitions
you know um and analytic philosophy is
all over the map you know um so is it
good to like read comparatively I would
say yeah um but you know you can't read
everybody and so you don't have to feel
bad about not reading everybody uh or
not even reading more than a fraction of
what's available you you figure out what
you are interested in and if you can if
you have a sense that you're missing out
on something go over there and check it
out just like if you you know like in in
in food right so you're walking down the
street you always just go to the same
pizza shop you know and you've had like
every single Pizza they make and they
calzones and mozzarella sticks and stuff
like that and you see another shop down
the way that's selling Indian food and
you're like oh I wonder if they make
they don't make pizzas I wonder what
they do make gold there and check it out
and take you know you don't have to eat
every single thing on the menu but go
there and see if you like it or not see
if it if it suits you if you find it
opens up culinary
gustatory
um what would you call it Horizons for
you I think you can do the same thing
with
philosophy um and you know realize that
that Continental philosophy and analytic
philosophy they don't name one single
thing they name a whole bunch of
different threads that all come together
you know um
so you know there there's a lot of
interesting variants in there that you
could you could check out all right Ken
is here so good to see you other than
reading the original
texts are there any strategies you would
recommend for guiding people away from
lowercase as stoicism broism to actual
stoicism um yeah so reading the original
text is important I I mean I guess I
would say part of it is a negative thing
quit reading the [__] crap that's
out there um so broism is when we have
stoicism that is being selectively
harnessed for uh a a mistaken conception
of traditional masculinity that that men
in the past would actually look at and
be like wow you're not you're not real
men all these these poser boys and the
present who you know take selfies at the
gym and talk about you know how they're
dating a 10 and and uh Miss Andre and
all this other other nonsense in the
manosphere
um just don't read that crap I mean you
know what I do when I see that sort of
stuff in my social media I block those
people because life is short and I'm not
going to get anything out of a
conversation with somebody who is all
butt hurt about how they can't find
anyone who wants to date them when
they're not datable because they're a
jerk you know um and I would say that so
lowercase as stoicism broism would be
part of that there's also the thing that
we kind of you know jokingly do stoicism
with the dollar sign and that's people
who don't know anything about stoicism
or they only know a little bit but
they're looking to cash in on the trend
you know and they're gonna offer you
coaching and they've got you know this
stoic and that stoic and they they've
always got to put stoic in their name
you know so like the stoic musician and
you know this stoic and and you know the
stoic gouret I'm just making stuff up at
this point but I'm willing to bet
there's probably a website out there
like that and they always want to like
they're they're always seeking after
this is something that you can apply to
the broism thing too they're always
seeking after things that the stoics the
real stoics uppercase s stoics
considered to be
externals money
Prestige pleasure power those are the
things that they're looking for you know
you know if you're going to use stoicism
to help you date better you're looking
to get laid you're looking for pleasure
you're trying to take the philosophy and
just little bits of it and sprinkle it
in and turn it into a recipe for having
some sexual pleasure right if you're
going to use it to try to make money
well we know exactly what you're after
in that case if you're gonna say
stoicism will help you improve your
workplace performance and that's what
you're really about that's an external
right so I would say you know you want
to read the original stoic text and then
when you when you come across people now
somebody might say well I'll just finish
with the thought when you come across
people who are clearly coming from
wrong-headed points of view just cut
them out block them you don't even have
to denounce them just don't engage with
them I like to block because I you know
I don't want to have to deal with those
jerks and I don't want them reading my
stuff because they're not worth my time
and you might say well wait a second
don't you have to don't you have a duty
to engage them no if they want to read
the original texts nobody's stopping
them right if they want to improve
themselves if they want to have a come
to Jesus moment there's plenty of other
people out there who can get on their
case and help them out with that I don't
have to do that you know there's 24
hours in a day I spend about eight of
them in bed and you know some doing
other stuff I don't have the time to
like fix everybody who's got a
wrong-headed view on stoicism and I
don't have a duty to do that and neither
do to any of you so I I encourage that
um any other things for guiding people
away from I mean so if you if you do see
somebody that you think is kind of like
ripe for a conversion to an actual
philosophy of life um you know you could
dialogue with them
and you know you could be you're get you
have to do that kind of gently because
if you do it too hard you're just going
to push them away and um they're
probably gonna act like kind of jerks
they'll be like oh man you just think
you're smarter because you've read more
books right how do you respond to that I
mean my response is hey if you don't
value reading books I probably don't
want to waste my time on you but you can
waste your time on those people it's
your time you can do whatever you want
with that right so all
right uh orille are there Ironclad
examples of philosophers that engaged in
esoteric writing or somehow put hidden
messages in their
texts just by definition there couldn't
be Ironclad examples because what you're
looking for is something that every
person would find convincing and if it's
esoteric if it's hidden messages in the
text
obviously uh most people aren't going to
get it I think that esotericism ism is a
big waste of time um one of the things
you know I won't say that Leo Strauss
and his followers are all stupid but
that is one of the really stupid things
that or features of Strauss and
straussian ISM that I have zero time for
at all you know if you're gonna make
claims and anybody can turn anything
into anything by Prof you know offering
an esoteric interpretation
um they're usually pretty
unconvincing and they're only convincing
to people that are you know primed and
desirous of having some hidden message
that other people aren't going to get
and they can feel smart and other people
are stupid and I think that's just for
me that's a waste of time and it's also
kind of a character trait that I find a
bit repugnant so you know I mean if you
can show the only way you're gonna show
uh that a philosopher or you know a
literary figure for example definitely
had some sort of esoteric project in
mind is if they say it
somewhere right so there's got to be a
letter there's got to be some sort of
extra part of the book where they're
like hey when I say x I really mean why
otherwise it's just you know people kind
of reading what they want to read in
into the the text and to me that's
that's just not very interesting at all
um we could waste time forever going on
and on about you know what what was
Shakespeare really trying to say I mean
sometimes the answer is right there on
the
surface so all right um David says I'm
new to reading philosophy I can't get
over how interesting buthus is I'm
moving on to the Republic by Plato next
love your channel Dr Sadler
well that's that's good um I wouldn't uh
go on to the Republic next I would go on
to some of Plato's shorter texts and by
buus you probably just mean the uh
consolation of philosophy and it is a
very very interesting text but if you
want to be kind of disabused about how
interesting I won't say brilliant
because it's also brilliant stuff buus
is then go on and read some of his
theological treaty or his commentaries
and you will find that a lot drier you
know because it is kind of dry stuff
it's interesting stuff as well but it's
not quite as compelling right um but I
you know I I I I usually when people are
going to start with PL I suggest
beginning with shorter dialogues rather
than trying to go directly into the
Republic but you can do whatever you
want I mean you can read the Republic
first and then come back to other stuff
it's a free country you can say
sexus empiricus says there's static in
the video not a damn thing I can do
about that right this is streaming um I
don't know why people you know think
that they should like notify me about
that because there's there's nothing I
can do I don't control the internet the
microphone is the microphone I got so
you just have to bear with it I guess uh
laps n Continuum great examples for the
ship athus discussion I'm a heavy metal
fan catch again got to catch that
upcoming stream with Ken that you
mentioned so that is coming up I want to
say uh the 20th is that the
Saturday um this month and you know we
do monthly yeah it is the 20th we do
monthly sessions me and Scott uh Ken is
a frequent guest and he'll be on camera
this time talking about his experiences
we've already Scott and I already
started thinking about what we want to
ask about so you know we we talk about
all sorts of cool philosophical topics
sometimes in ethics sometimes yeah
sometimes music history sometimes uh
metaphysics so yeah you you you can
always find out when it's going to be by
looking at the monthly update video or
by going to the reason iioe events
calendar where all of these things are
or by looking at my Facebook page where
I I post those as well um Zach says
I wanted you to know I'm now a full-time
Professor I'm so excited hope you're
doing well any thoughts on philosophy of
and music well that's that's great and
that is extraordinarily good in these
times when full-time jobs are kind of
hard to get you
unfortunately a lot of the academic
institutions certainly in the humanities
are not replacing professors who leave
or retire Marquette University where I
sometimes teach is a great example I was
just talking with one of the older
professors who is uh debating about
retiring because if he does retire he
knows he won't be replaced and he does
um you know Arabic philosophy and a lot
of medieval stuff and it kind of sucks
right if if they don't
um they don't want to replace these
people so congratulations on getting the
degree uh you know make sure that you
use your position well um you do have to
kind of you know jump through a lot of
Hoops to get 10 year and all that but be
be a decent person to the adjuncts who
are also your colleagues um so that
that's you know kind of important stuff
um but philosophy and philosophy of and
music so philosophers have been talking
about music really since the time of
Plato you know in Republic
um book three it's two or three there's
a discussion of the different modes of
music and you see a similar discussion
in
Aristotle's politics I want to say book
Seven uh Aristotle actually had a
student who was a he wrote a treaties on
music but the student didn't like
Aristotle or exos and he said bad stuff
about Aristotle buthus has a treaties on
music or on Harmony perhaps it's called
so there's a lot of stuff out there
philosophers thinking about music and
there's interestingly quite a few people
just to mention heavy metal there are
quite a few people out there doing work
on um heavy metal and philosophy because
there's there's these interesting topics
like you know is a band still the same
band why why do we respond to music in
the way that we do should we have lyrics
about this or is this a bad idea you
know all sorts of interesting questions
that are that are
around
all right jelmer I've been in isolation
for about 10 years and spend lots of
time writing My Philosophy I'm scared to
share it with the world because I'm
self-taught and think I'm amateurish any
thoughts um you don't have to do it all
at once you know you could like uh write
short selections from it and put that
out there and see what people think um
if you have been you know like doing
everything on your own and not engaging
with other people should expect that a
lot of people will probably not
understand the jargon if you've created
any new terminology that you're
using way that are different
than you know you should sort of predict
ahead of time that
people by that and so maybe you want to
include some discussions of that in
there
and um there's lots of people who are
you know working on their own philosophy
oftentimes what you do find is it ends
up um having a lot of similarities with
somebody else in the past which isn't to
say that it's bad right I mean you
manage to come across something and
figure something out on your own it just
so happens for example um my Master's
thesis basically ended up being covering
the same ground as da speech and
phenomena only Dara kind of did
better as far as I know I mean maybe
there's at least one respect in which my
Master's thesis which I haven't looked
at since
1997 um did something you know but I was
basically saying okay you got holl and I
was using the passive synthesis lectures
that were being translated at the time
by Tony Steinbach and um diser and
structural Linguistics to kind of inform
that that's what Dara did right so you
may find that that happens to be the
case with your
philosophy but that's okay you know you
can say great minds think alike in that
case doesn't mean that it's it's um
valueless but yeah what I would do is I
would trickle out some stuff rather than
like you know putting your Magnus Opus
out there and saying everybody read this
um and see what people make of it you
know um open yourself up to discussion
with other people and you don't have to
do it all at once you know um you can do
it the way that that you want to
right all right
um let's see I'm gonna skip over the the
kind of silliness about static and noise
and all that um I don't know if that's
on your end or my end or what's going on
I'm not gonna worry about it uh Alex
says did common Romans find senica's
poverty role playing patronizing or is
that feeling a more modern thinking
we'll say this we don't have a clue
about what common Romans thought about
senica's uh and he didn't do poverty
role playing he deliberately did
exercises to try to live poorly uh as
part of what you do as a stoic stoicism
is something you can practice whatever
level of society you're in so for you to
call it poverty role playing already
shows what you think of it but I don't
have a problem with it myself you know
uh but we don't have a clue what other
common Romans thought about it because
they didn't write anything down um in
part because they were working jobs and
uh they weren't literate you know so how
would we possibly
know um we we don't have a lot of
discussion from that time I mean Donald
Robertson has drawn some interesting
inferences basically from
epictetus's lack of mention of senica
and and Marcus aurelius's lack of
mention of senica but I think perhaps
that's going a bit too far we we don't
really know in a lot of cases you know
when it comes to what epicus thought we
have the discourses that Aryan wrote and
we only have half of them we they're
originally eight books we only have four
and that's only from the time period
that Aryan was studying with epicus we
don't know what he said after Aryan left
so it's one of those things we just
don't we don't have enough information
one way or another you
know all right
um black prairie what do you think of
Marcel Duchamp and the whole daada
Vanguard not much um it's you know it's
something that we teach in uh art
history and aesthetic classes but you
know a lot of people reference it but
um it's kind of gimmicky right there's I
guess it was supposed to teach us some
lessons about the nature and boundaries
of art so you know like a lot of things
where somebody is doing something
revolutionary couple Generations later
you're kind of like yeah okay we all
know that now uh and you can say Well
they're the reason you all know that now
yeah but we don't all live in a museum
so I don't know I I just don't find it
all that
um
interesting it's stuff that of course
you get exposed to but you know what are
you gonna do with it are you gonna make
another urinal and put it in a museum
good luck getting somebody to buy it
because it's already been done you know
you're gonna make a meme about you know
this not being a pipe um It's Kind been
kind of done to death so I don't
know I I just I don't see a lot of uh as
James used to call it William James the
the cash value of an idea I think that
you know the inflation has really driven
down the cash value of of
dotism
um David kabiri what do you think about
art and philosophy are they connected
philosophy's connected to everything and
arts connected to everything when you
when you have these like
gigantic you know huge top level abstra
actions like philosophy and art or
philosophy and religion or philosophy
and music or you know the economy and
philosophy they of course they're going
to be connected because everything is
connected in one way or another and why
wouldn't you know a discipline that uh
has over in the west you know 2500 years
of development be connected with some
other phenomena that's been around even
longer I mean Plato speculates about art
in in his his Works doesn't he and so
does Aristotle and so do other thinkers
so obviously there's going to be
connections and artists are often
inspired by philosophy or they they take
philosophical ideas and um depict them
you know for example Edward munches the
scream right which by the way is not the
figure screaming the figure is trying to
drown out the scream of nature why is
there a scream well this is inspired by
kard you know by the way that's I'm
teaching an existentialism class this
semester at Milwaukee Institute of Art
and
Design and um that's what we start with
is Edward Munch who by the way also did
a portrait of guess who Fredick n right
so there's all sorts of connections
between artists and um philosophers you
just got to kind of look in there to to
find them and these are not like totally
separate disciplines I mean the fact
that at Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design I got hired to teach philosophy
classes because they wanted some of that
in the curriculum that that kind of
tells you something doesn't it about the
interconnection between these these
disciplines uh Zach thanks for your
thoughtful response I feel it a
privilege and responsibility to be
teaching philosophy yeah it's it's you
know as we say good work if you can get
it um and that's that's great and I hope
that you have a long and uh uh
productive career ahead you know we
don't know what things are going to look
like in the educational landscape 20 30
years down the line but we don't even
know what the environment's going to
look like 20 30 years down the line um
so you know do the do the best that you
can um you know a little another little
bit of advice that I'll give just drawn
from my own experience
is and you you probably have heard me
say this uh in in my video about service
classes the most important classes that
you teach are those that you're teaching
as gened to non- Majors to the business
majors the psychology Majors the nursing
Majors the fashion Majors all the people
that aren't going to study
philosophy as part of their their
standard curriculum because that's the
one chance that we have to introduce
them to what philosophy can do for them
right and so we get to put the bug in
their ear and so the the best way that I
found for doing that besides like having
examples they can relate to is taking
their fields seriously not not being
like Oh you're not studying philosophy
so you know you're not a real thinker
you know business business ethics or
nursing ethics or stuff like that those
are classes that really pay huge
dividends when you can you can get them
to see oh yeah there's this discipline
over here and I can access the stuff in
that discipline the rest of my life
basically for free I just got to know
where to go for it uh and I'm not going
to get it in my my business classes or
my nursing classes in the same way when
you get them to realize that and you
know three five 10 years down the line
remember oh yeah I can I can go to this
discipline as a
resource you're making an impact on the
world in a way that writing the next
being in time won't you know or teaching
a bunch of graduate students graduate
students by the way easy to teach you
know you just give them a bunch of
readings and you know make them do some
presentations in class they're all
go-getters they basically all you know
are are driven into the discipline you
may have to give them some some
refinement and stuff like that but
they're easy to teach undergraduates are
a lot harder to teach and non- majors
are the hardest to teach because they
come in and they're like why do I have
to take this [__] ethics class why
do I have to take this stupid logic
class right but it's the chance that we
have for engaging with
it um all
right jelmer deg rout uh happens all the
time my big breakthrough has already
been thought of but it's a good sign I
wrote my own dictionary so terminology
is a thing uh thanks for your response
okay good yeah so so you've you've got
some of this stuff already you know
figured out in advance that's that's
good uh that'll be helpful for you uh
Simon day have you ever read Hitler's my
struggle mine comp uh will you ever why
why not I'm conflicted about reading it
yeah I've read parts of it um and it's
it's an interesting work you can clearly
see what what he thought about stuff and
you know why read it well because you
want to understand um what was
motivating the Nazi regime and what's
motivating white supremacists today who
are into that sort of
thing right so it's it's you know it's
sort of like worth reading in order to
just like reading Donald Trump's the art
of the deal right I mean it's not great
literature um but it gives you an
insight into the minds of that that
person right and the people that they
they've
influenced um I wouldn't become like a
mind Camp Specialist or anything right
that would be in my view a waste of
one's time and and a life you know um
but it's you know why feel conflicted
about reading it I mean you could if
you're going to feel conflicted about
reading that you know crazy racist who
uh created a lot of evil in the world
well then we should feel conflicted
about reading all sorts of other stuff
as well it's it's interesting because
you know Hitler often winds up being
sort of like the limit case for the most
you know Wicked or evil sort of person
but he I think he just kind of happened
to get there right um and you can see
all sorts of like it shows you what
structuring your
worldview and political philosophy
around the concept of
race um which isn't by the way exactly
the same as you know like our current
concepts of of
race a lot of people that you know love
Hitler these days Hitler would have put
in the camps and gas um it shows you
what that leads to it shows you the
limitations of that kind of kind of
thinking right
um Brandon is giving advice you can just
read the 2025 project menu
memo I mean I I don't think you have to
give people advice about what they
should be reading instead if somebody
wants to read mine comp let him read
mine comp right um all right Andre says
are you familiar with the book on
walking from Henry through Ro I haven't
read that I've read a good bit of other
thorough stuff obviously Walden right
everybody reads that in high school and
then his uh letters that he had with
that woman I forget exact it's like
letters to a a sear Seeker something
like that and of course you know uh some
of his his other things but I haven't I
haven't read that um so yeah all right
um any other questions that people have
I'm gonna take a little break for my
vocal cords
and enjoy some of this non-alcoholic
IPA we bought this a while back true
Roots Brewing Company IPA uh it's good
stuff I like these these uh
non-alcoholic beers because I I like the
taste of beer I like hops I like barley
and all that um but can't drink alcohol
anymore so um Na you know used to be
that nonalcoholic stuff just sucked you
know you had odou and cl huler and they
were terrible but now we have like this
amazing selection you know you can get
Guinness that's non-alcoholic that
tastes just like real Guinness you know
got some of that downstairs you got all
these companies out there like you know
two Roots we got a local company here in
Milwaukee making
non-alcoholic um all right jack says
just getting into Hegel with your help
do you recommend xek too no I don't
recommend xek I you know xek is is uh he
in the early days xek was kind of a
rigorous scholar and I like reading his
early stuff and then same thing happen
happened to him as happened to Dara
right became a star started putting out
like all of his random thoughts about
stuff because everybody's gonna listen
to him and I think there was a marked
decline in quality right and some of
this stuff in the present is interesting
a lot of it you're like there's no
actual like it's just like jumping from
thought to thought to thought with a lot
of jargon and
terminology I I understand that he has
some cache or prestige but why wouldn't
if you want to read other people on
Hegel why wouldn't you just go to actual
Hegel Scholars that are out there that
you know there's like an entire two
centuries of work on Hegel that you can
go back to and well not quite two
centuries but close to it that you can
read if you want to certainly in the
20th century you know I mean if if you
want to get a good appreciation of hate
you don't want anybody who's flashy you
want people who are kind of boring and
you know just going to stick to the
texts and work their way through it I
mean if you want to like contemporary
people um you know Robert brandom has a
a good new work on on hegot is it
perfect no but it isn't gonna be like
all over the map all the time so yeah I
mean I'm I'm you can tell I'm not a big
fan of
xjek um but uh it seems like a lot of
people are and uh that's fine I think
that 100 years from now people are still
going to be reading Hegel they're
probably not gonna be reading xek
anymore I don't know if they're gonna be
reading Dara anymore quite frankly you
know so all right um let's see here
Brandon says what are some of the
background texts you need to read before
taking on city of God or is that
unnecessary you don't need to read
background texts before reading any work
really um it can be helpful but you can
generally read works on their own um
there's no need there's more of a it
might be helpful to to do this I mean I
wouldn't jump into city of God if that
was my first Augustine writing I would
probably read a shorter work U I'm not
even sure that the confessions would be
my first Augustine work
right um Augustine is going to reference
a lot of people people in the city of
God some of whom we still read today
some of whom we don't really read
anymore um it would be useful to know
the context of it which is that it's a a
sustained pmic and systematic response
to calus's claims that Christianity had
been undermining uh the Roman Empire um
so Augustine is responding to that right
so all right
um pck Williams which was a better time
in your life 20s or
30s that's that's an interesting one
um and it's a hard one to answer so my
20s
included um going to
college and most of my graduate school
and a year in between where I lived here
in
Milwaukee and worked as a third sh
security guard uh worked on my languages
was in a a relationship actually a
couple
relationships and um also worked as a
barista and then also got to travel to
Europe and Quebec in in
95 um my 30s included finishing graduate
school and my 20s were also marked by
the death of my mother um and then
having to starting to handle her estate
my 30s were marked by um getting married
and with to somebody who is definitely
the wrong person for me but with whom
I've had two kids and I you know
wouldn't have them if if I hadn't gotten
married and spending a lot of time uh
with my family uh in Indiana living on
family land and then going down to
fville State University and then also
reconnecting with uh the right person
for me who I didn't marry in my 30s but
fell in love with in the end of my
30s
um so it's hard to compare the two you
know
um I mean both of them were pretty good
on the whole both of them had some real
challenges and
problems
but yeah I I I don't know what I would
how I would answer
that
um let's see here um Simon Says many
people in online discourse use logical
fallacy terms like strawman and hominum
but it often seems people just use these
lazily as thought stopping statements
what do you think of that I think that's
completely right yeah I think a lot of
people play games with logical fallacies
and they're basically gotcha so I can
dismiss everything that you have to say
which is you know
essentially uh genetic fallacy or ad
hominum is isn't it so yeah I
mean it's it's good that people know the
terms I think that there's a lot of
people who are very sloppy and uh quick
to jump in and make accusations based on
fallacies as a matter of fact Dan Hayes
my my co-host for the wisdom for Life
show and I did a show just about
misapplications of fallacies a while
back uh let me see if I can find the uh
actual
episode
um and you know what we were doing is
we're saying you know people often don't
know sometimes they Al so it's number 73
uh Mis applications of informal
fallacies we're saying sometimes people
get it wrong so not every insult is an
ad hominum you have to be dismissing the
person's claim or argument by making
some sort of personal attack
otherwise it's not an ad hominum so if I
say uh wow that was a really stupid
personal attack on your part you're
probably full of crap we shouldn't
listen to you that's an ad hominum right
so or it could be I mean maybe we should
dismiss people on the basis of making
stupid personal attacks maybe we
shouldn't let them have a place at the
table right
[Music]
um so yeah I would say this is a big
problem um there is actually a fallacy
out there the fallacy of misdescribed
fallacies but it's not very useful to to
bring that up I think with with people
so all right um so Andre uh says I used
to find myself more in agreement with
Thomas [__] now I find myself closer at
understanding to Carl
poer uh I mentioned Norman Barry because
of my need of distancing myself from
so-called French Theory at College I was
bombarded with levinas habas dared da
Fuko [__] little r for popper Berry
Hayek Etc I don't know why why you'd
want to read Hayek I mean he's he's not
of the caliber of uh habas and Fuko and
dareda uh and it's not like you have to
choose between poer and and [__] I mean
popper says a lot of asinine things
doesn't he in in quite a few Works um
but he's you know sometimes interesting
and and useful but it's it kind of feels
like you're you're choosing between two
few Alternatives and posing them as if
they're like opposites to each other
when really they're more like at you
know different angles to each other
dealing with similar similar
matters all right um amorphus what are
your thoughts on Nick Lan's philosophy
and do you like his use of Delo and gari
so I was very disappointed when reading
L Fang Numa and I've actually been you
know on um some some podcasts like acid
Horizon did a thing about Nick land a
while back that I was invited on to talk
about where we talked not just about
Fang numina but also his more recent
work uh in terms of dark Enlightenment
and I I just I don't get the prestige
and the aura around uh land he's just
kind of in my view a second maybe Third
Rate uh Continental philosopher who was
doing the kind of stuff that we all did
back then in in the 90s you know playing
fast and loose with ideas that we took
from it could be Delo andari or if you
actually read Fang num it's Kant and n
and haiger and all these people right
and mixing in some ideas about
cybernetics and capitalism and all that
and it's interesting but there's not an
awful lot of like
coherent um connected here's here's what
I'm saying and here's the basis for it
it's it's the same sort of problem as
with xek it's just this freewheeling hey
here's some ideas I'm going to throw
them around yeah yeah let's get into
this you know and we all love doing that
sort of crap back then but it's it's not
great
philosophy
so you know I was you know I'd heard so
much about how how brilliant this guy
was and then when I started reading Fang
Newman I was like okay it's not bad but
it ain't great so how did this guy
become the darling of so many people out
there and I and I've I've got a video
out there on text with auras I think
it's the same thing as like people who
don't understand Spinosa but love to
talk about Spinosa or Hegel or for a
while it was dareda and on grammatology
or delusion guari anti- atopus you
know there's there's this tendency for a
lot of
um let's call it replication and and you
could use it you could Ed Delo andari to
understand this right you know
replication production um people just
kind of like uh you know reproduce these
tropes that they got from it and it's
very superficial there's not a lot of
depth to it now I think there are a few
ideas here and
there that could be quite interesting in
Fang Numa the stuff that he was doing in
dark Enlightenment it's just not very
good at all so there's a marked decline
in
quality
um and I haven't read enough of his
other stuff to say much of anything so
all right uh Raina what's the best way
to study McIntyre Alistair McIntyre
right well I would say why not begin
with after virtue that's his most famous
work and it gets you ready to go into
the next three parts of the tetrology
which is who's Justice which rationality
uh three rival versions of moral inquiry
and then um dependent rational animals
those are four books that all kind of
hang together he's got lots of great
essays on stuff I've got resources on
McIntyre that you can check out um some
of which are on after virtue some of
which are on uh some of his shorter
essays I actually in ethics classes
often start out my students with plain
persons and moral theory which I think
is a great uh short little essay that
has a lot of interesting themes in it um
um he's got earlier stuff that's well
worth reading to like against the self
images of the age he's got a great
edited volume out on
Hegel um where he's got this great
article Hegel on faces and skulls
talking about the phen phenology and
physiognomy section um so there's you
know there's lots of ways that you could
come in and look at the
guy um let's see
here
we're almost we're pretty much past time
and I have another thing I got to do a
little bit later today Johan erinson uh
read in a comment from you John Milbank
and the radical Orthodox crowd
misunderstands Blondell can you please
expand on that thanks for the videos I
mean they basically just read locko and
um I don't think they they actually read
much of the rest of his work um it's
been a while since I've looked at at
Milbank so I can't give you exact stuff
but I can tell you that reading um his
philosop what was it philosophy and
social
theory um you know as I'm reading the
stuff about Blondell I like well that's
not right that's not right where did he
get this from you know so
um all right uh we'll go out on this one
from
Luca as someone who has gone through a
nitian phase what would you say one
misses when one emra Embraces a nan
perspective unilaterally well the here's
what you miss there is no single nitian
perspective to embrace
unilaterally there's a lot of ways of
interpreting n and he's not consistent
from work to work to work so that's a
big challenge right there um but I will
just say this you know most people
including myself when I was identifying
as a nian who are claiming to be nians
are really just acting like selfish
jerks and and being you know elitist
for maybe good reasons maybe bad reasons
in the process but you know that's as
good as it it it gets in being a
follower or a um life interpreter of n i
I don't think that nche is the kind of
person that you want to be a Ian kind of
follower right I think what you want to
do is take the parts of n that are
actually valuable and insightful and
interesting and use those and um leave
the rest behind I mean he says a lot of
stupid stupid things about women for
example right um you don't you don't
need to embrace his um you know misogyny
in order to understand him any more than
you do with shopau for that matter um
and you know he's probably got a lot of
other things wrong you know so all right
so I'm going to wrap up here because I
got to give get some food in me before I
got to meet with uh patreon supporters
for the philosophy chat um thanks for
everybody's questions and comments
thanks for joining me on this winter day
although depending on where you are in
the world might not be winter if you're
in Africa or South America or Australia
so I will see you down the line at some
of our other events and we do these
every month uh usually first Saturday of
the month so I will see you there
okay